okay alex cooper so now that you're the
one being interviewed do you call me
daddy now i think i can call you daddy
i'm obsessed with the necklace i'm
obsessed with the eyeliner i'm obsessed
with you
thank you thank you thank you i
appreciate it so first of all you've
been an athlete you've dated athletes
and now you have basically an athlete's
contract okay
60 million dollars an exclusive deal
with spotify girl
thank you thank you thank you how does
it feel to be earning more than all of
your ex-boyfriends
well that's actually nice i will say
that is nice but no in all honesty i i
feel so
immensely grateful just because
as a woman in the industry you know you
see men get these contracts and i just
feel like it's such a big moment just
for women in general in this industry i
felt like i'm fortunate it was me but
like as a woman just looking if this
happened to another woman i would be
like f yes like let's go yes
it's empowering and it's exciting i just
want people other women to see like it
you can do it absolutely we can do it
yeah what are you gonna like are you
gonna go on a shopping spree side note i
just took this in wait 16 i'm like wait
hold on girl wait what are we buying
like you know what i'm actually pretty
frugal with my money the thing that i'm
like investing in is having a team
around me and like employees like i've
done this by myself for so long and it's
been really rewarding to be able to hire
so many women that are helping
contribute to the products so i'm not
like the weird girl alone in my room
like just like talking into a microphone
by myself all the time now so that's
that's been nice but no i haven't bought
anything
wow i'm so impressed yes queen i'm so
excited for you okay from this deal uh
to forbes 30 under 30 to sitting down
with some of the biggest stars in the
world on a daily basis like how wild has
this all been for you
it's definitely weird i mean i'm sitting
down with people that i remember like
watching growing up and i'm like having
them in my house and they're opening up
about their lives to me so it's re it is
a little strange but it's so exciting
and it makes it that much more of a wild
ride but i just feel like it's it just
shows the evolution of the show and the
growth of the show of getting these big
names is really just a testament to how
much the show has an impact on our like
social media culture today and it's been
cool to see how my listeners are just
open to me trying everything i mean my
my content changes every week you kind
of never know what you're going to get
from caller daddy right now which i
personally love i don't want to be put
into a box i don't want to have to have
like one specific narrative that i'm
pushing like whatever comes to me that
week like i'm just going for it i love
that it is it is unpredictable that's
what makes it so exciting as a listener
um at the beginning of your career like
there were a ton of naysayers and people
who didn't understand that you were
building a brand now that it has taken
off the way that it has you know how
does it feel now to to shut down the
haters
i love the haters i i know i'm always a
bit of a controversial one just in terms
of like i love the talk i it fuels me i
was a competitive athlete myself like i
love being competitive yeah it's not
even more of like saying like of you to
the haters if anything like it just
keeps speaking for itself and like every
time call her daddy keeps getting those
big wins all i have to do is say thank
you to my listeners because they've
stuck with me but it is a little sweet
moment when everyone's like talking and
then i'm like oh coming out this week
here's another interview that's a banger
and so it's just like i just let the
work
speak for itself which is
fun
yeah you know it's always challenging
like as a tv personality also um it's
challenging because you want to give so
much of yourself to people but then
there's like that weird balance so like
how do you balance your personal life
and your friends and your family with
the amount of things that you do share
on your podcast like it must it must
affect your dating because like guys can
easily like hear who you've dated in the
past and like crazy that you'd be saying
and totally totally
i know in the beginning of caller daddy
it was really hard for me to establish
boundaries just because there's no
playbook like no one had really ever
done this unless like kind of reality
people but it was in a different medium
that i started doing it so for sure in
the beginning it was hard i think for me
it's actually just establishing
boundaries where it's like this is my
life the podcast means everything to me
and then relationships kind of were
taking a back seat had to fall in line
and be like you gotta respect what i'm
doing but with my boyfriend now like
we've definitely established boundaries
of like hey if i'm gonna talk about our
sex life or i'm gonna talk about a fight
we had i'd give him a heads up prior but
i mean it's there's no no it still is
weird at times i think not reading the
comments and turning off my comments on
social media it's kind of just given me
that ability to like reclaim my power
which i honestly encourage everyone to
do i feel like i spend less time on
social media i'm less invested in what
people are saying about me um and i just
keep my dms open because my listeners
are telling me what they want for the
show but i don't need to know if someone
doesn't like my hair that day like keep
yourself
yeah life must be so blissful without
the comments like that's such a huge
part of the day
i feel like i'm on like a retreat i'm
like at a spa a permanent spa now like
no seriously it truly has affected my
mental health in such a positive way and
like i don't i can't ever see myself
going back
yeah can you do this setting where like
the people you follow who your friends
are the only ones that can like drake
does that like only his friends
yeah i've seen like haley bieber does
that yeah but actually there is
something about literally not one person
being able to comment like i love my
photo and that's all i need to know
period don't care don't care if you like
it yes period so how do you plan your
podcast like what is the strategy
because there has to be they all are
unpredictable for the viewers and the
listeners but i know there's a rhyme and
reason with from you yeah i work on this
show seven days a week it's like i live
and breathe it i in a beautiful way i
think this season has kind of take
taken like a very specific trajectory
where there's three different lanes it's
having on big guests that come down and
sit with me and i interview them and
they really open up maybe about things
that they don't even like talk about
with their close friends but creating an
environment where my guest feels really
safe to open up and having big a-list
names is cool to have kind of break down
the barrier where you may not know this
about this person or you may have
pre-judgments about them and then they
sit down with me and you're like wait i
actually that person is so nice or that
like now i can empathize with them then
i have my solo episodes which are like
my little bread and butter and i love
them and it's when i really feel like i
need to connect back with my listeners
like hey guys we've been doing
interviews for a while we haven't had a
sit down that's when i gauge like i
think i need to just talk with them
personally and then the mental health
aspect i've started having on um
therapists and doctors who i'm very
fortunate having this platform that i
have the accessibility to have these
people on my show and so giving people
maybe who can't afford therapy um the
opportunity to get advice from people by
using my platform and giving them that
opportunity to get advice from a
professional i love that um what makes a
guest perfect to you where you're like i
need to have you on the show because
you're pretty fearless jamie lynn spears
julia
you know what i think it's interesting
like i
everyone deserves to have an opportunity
to speak and i i'm interested in just
having interesting conversations there's
no
surprise those are the most downloaded
episodes and so it's like people as much
as they may talk we want
let's be a little bit more open and the
notion of cancel culture for a minute
now i think everyone's like let's just
hear what people have to say and so i
love having even controversial
conversations like that's who i am
outside of the podcast like i want to
hear what you're thinking tell me let me
pick your brain so i think though for a
perfect guest it's someone that's
willing to just be extremely open and
vulnerable and not have any
thing that's off-limits so that you can
actually get to the crux of who they are
what they're thinking because it makes
for such a better show and it's probably
better for them you really get to know a
lot of people aren't bad people
misunderstood especially with social
media so i think that this podcast has
allowed people to really be seen as a
whole who they are because you're
hearing them in long-form content it's
not just a five-minute interview
yeah is there somebody that's been
canceled that you absolutely would not
allow on your show
probably like harvey weinstein you know
that would not be uh kosher but
like there's a lot of people that have
been canceled that if you really get
down to it it's like did they really do
something bad or did the internet just
not like what they were doing and so i
think like yeah i mean that's why jamie
lynn spears i was like i want to hear
what you have to say and i think
we all kind of wanted to hear what she
had to say and so
i'm i'm down to always have
conversations and i really think it's
interesting when people get all fumed
and mad but it's like they're the first
ones to click so i'm not trying to pick
these people off i'm trying to show
people like we're all human beings and
we make decisions because of something
in our life that happened like let's
hear about it yeah i absolutely feel the
same way oh my god um who
were you the biggest fan of that you
interviewed because you do have a lot of
big names you've been reviewed already
it does vary because my like um intake
of social media and pop culture varies
of who i like i mean obviously back in
the day miley cyrus i was like
um a huge fan of emma chamberlain i mean
i have such
an extreme appreciation for how much she
puts into her content and getting to sit
down with a creator that cares so much
about her vlogs like i care about my
podcast and how much goes into it it was
pretty cool to sit down with emma just
to even just pick her brain and have a
conversation with her and amanda knox
was
one of the most incredible interviews
i've ever done i would say if you
everyone hasn't listened go listen
because it's pretty it's pretty wild
when you being like that that you're a
big miley cyrus fan and you got to
interview her and 90s baby hannah
montana all of that was there anybody in
your family that was like really hannah
montana like did people in your like
family and friends yeah
my childhood friends were like are you
going to show her the video of you doing
a little rendition of her like hannah
montana theme song or not and i'm like
no i don't want her to kick me out of
the house
we'll save the fan girl moment for after
the interview oh my goodness okay you
gotta give us the tea the tea is piping
hot i need it i need to serve it okay
who do you have lined up
i have a lot of people that i'm working
on getting that maybe you've been
watching a really big tv show of theirs
um
i hate giving away my guests because i
like the build up like i love marketing
and i love giving so i would just say
maybe a big tv show that you've been a
lot of people have been watching maybe
we'll get a guess from that the bachelor
big brother
none of those don't you love the
bachelor
i do but i think it's getting a little
tired
oh it's tired oh my god maybe they need
you to do something with them maybe i
should be the host
i don't know if i'm tired
screw the bachelor okay i'm going to
keep trying to guess
i think there the thing is is also just
to give you insight like my guests come
if i wake up in the morning and i check
my tick tock feed and i see something or
i took my check my instagram and i'm
like this person is interesting i just
dm them like there's no a lot of times
there's not a rhyme or reason other than
i'm sipping my coffee in the morning and
i see someone making moves on the
internet whether it's controversial or
it's being praised and i just go out to
them so yeah i think that there's a lot
of people i mean
there's someone that a netflix series
was just made about
there's controversial things that i like
to do uh that may become a podcast
that's what i can say
kanye
west yeah connie if you want to come
over
yes at this point who was the most
difficult celeb to get it just took the
most effort to get to convince them
that's a really interesting question
i've been very fortunate that when i've
gone out to people
i've gotten pretty immediate responses
yeah um
oh
i don't even i don't think i've had that
is that
bad to say i don't think i've had that
hard of a time getting
guests oh okay
well no not in like a bragging way it's
actually just been like i think in the
moment like with my guest it's yeah
of like i have an amazing listener base
that they'll dm the person if they want
them to come on um so it's like it's a
big like stream of people that when i'm
like daddy gang we want to get this
person on like we push for it and
usually it works i love that taylor
swift though so that that
i haven't gotten it but
that's the one